so DISA I've read that you usually lean
on comedy with your work so I'm curious
with a romantic drama like this what did
you find yourself leaning on that was
new that maybe you could take on to
future projects I leaned on my morals I
lean on my private parts in my heart I
feel like everyone should take that
motto into whatever they do acting or
not for both of you I know that you
didn't have all that much rehearsal time
on this project is that something that
you find exciting just jumping into
something or do you prefer to have the
rehearsal time before you start your
scenes so depends on what we're doing
more technical stuff I think it's nice
to have nice preparations
we're not fumbling all over the place
but for some things some things I
require just a sort of a heart
interaction I'd like to play around or
comedy type things is nice to just kind
of throw stuff out there sometimes seems
you follow so you know just depends on
circumstance with me yeah I think it was
something like this you're getting to
know the first thing in real life and on
screen and so using that to inform the
relationship is helpful too so I find
that fun I have to ask you in particular
about working it with the the two young
co-stars that you have in that one scene
because got the biggest laugh for me and
I think the biggest laugh throughout the
entire theater so when you're shooting a
scene like that is it mostly improvising
or are all of those comedic beads kind
of timed out perfectly where you know
them going in that was all scripted I'm
pretty sure the the girls were wonderful
they were so precious
and yeah I think they just they had the
kinetic timing humor that that whole
stuff in the in the the apartment with
Lola realm just across the board that
was they impressed all right I figured
with him so do you like do you like
improvisation I'm not quite that fast
but do you like it I mean it's much more
fun when you're doing people with people
like and we're just naturally just
hilarious and
because sometimes it's hard to focus as
you know so now I have to ask you about
your Joker comments because I firmly
believe you could do absolutely anything
you set your mind to it and if I have to
keep talking about it to will this idea
into existence I'm going to do it so if
you had the opportunity to start a new
Joker movie what would you bring to the
character that we have yet to see on the
big screen I'm glad that you see a page
I hope you feel this you know I do you
know thank you very much I think what I
bring to it would have a lot to do with
who I collaborate with and how the
story's written and what world we exist
in and then I'll go do my little magic
anyone in mind you would want to
collaborate with from a directing
standpoint there's so many that comes
along and wouldn't it be crazy to Mina
satis do something like that I'm not
gonna get that out of my head now I have
to find a reason to interview them again
so I could put this in their mind no no
I made right here I want to see that
happen so this movie is largely about a
photograph and just the history and the
meaning that comes from that one
photograph we have phones with thousands
of photographs so two questions first I
want to know what is the thing on your
phone that you have the most photographs
of is it family food pets so bees you
name it right now it's a lot of niece
and nephew pictures yeah I always hit my
family group shut up cuz my are my
siblings with the exception of one have
kids now and I'm always like yo cinema
like do a better job come on good
answers do you have a most meaningful
photo um a mouse meeting meeting for
photo that's too hard I have too many
photos around the house and I just
started printing photos again so that's
been really exciting but deciding which
ones go up are challenging yeah yeah I
own a digital diary things now so
sometimes the weirdest things gonna have
sentimental value depending on what was
happening at the time what is that
oh it's like a diary to down looks like
an app and you just like you know you
can update it every day it's easier for
me than having a physical and you can
just put pictures in and the pictures
can take you back to that time so like I
got pictures of just like a cup and I'd
be like oh that's that night